Francesca Modena headed a fought on the
frontlines of El Salvador Civil War and
now fights for women's rights today
Joseph pero como possible SE ela Wharton
El Salvador latina Teochew a nose cone
with possibly a mujer con de nada hot
drink Tonya morena tells me that even in
cases where the cause of a miscarriage
or stillbirth is undetermined
the woman's charge is often increased
from abortion to aggravated homicide
Auto Mesa gravely dónde vienes Lakhan de
nada Trenton yo sabía que estaban Percy
yendo no hospital incluso a via ayuda a
la muchacha Hika par de l'hôpital the
district capital C a passer que en el
propio potala detaining
[Music]